Caption: hello and welcome so quick question
Caption: or by razer hands who here writes fast
Caption: software or thinks they write fast
Caption: software
Caption: who here thinks can write kind of fast
Caption: who thinks they write slow software
Caption: who thinks they don't write fast
Caption: software at all
Caption: now i'll get to that in a moment
Caption: so thank you for the amazing sponsors uh
Caption: for which ddd wouldn't happen
Caption: and who am i i'm the founder of office
Caption: floor so office 4 is the inversion of
Caption: coupling control container bit like
Caption: inversion of control
Caption: except that it takes it further it takes
Caption: it not just only to injecting dependency
Caption: injecting objects it injects threads and
Caption: it injects functions and it's a
Caption: different way of looking things in
Caption: solving many of the underlying patterns
Caption: but if you want to know more about that
Caption: see my previous dvd presentation today
Caption: we're talking about office law's web
Caption: server
Caption: now the first question you have is
Caption: why write a web server there's so many
Caption: of them out there and office floor being
Caption: an inversion control container can
Caption: inject them all in and use them as
Caption: necessary so why did i go to the effort
Caption: of actually writing an own web server
Caption: well it comes to what we're doing more
Caption: and more with our modern day apps
Caption: now if you have an sba application that
Caption: loads up and starts firing requests at
Caption: your server the specs actually say your
Caption: browser is only allowed to have two
Caption: connections to the server now some of
Caption: the browsers have pushed that further
Caption: and gone four to six and eight in three
Caption: cases but they limit the number of
Caption: connections to servers so if you've got
Caption: two requests going down on two
Caption: connections
Caption: the big problem is the request the web
Caption: server will only service one of those
Caption: requests off the connection at a time
Caption: so if you've got two long running
Caption: requests
Caption: and lots of requests behind it you get
Caption: loading on the page
Caption: so what we've done in office floor is
Caption: that we process all the requests off the
Caption: connection concurrently so as the
Caption: requests come in it process it doesn't
Caption: just do one it actually processes more
Caption: and more and what you get is you get
Caption: reduced latency so this everything just
Caption: gets processed and then sent back to the
Caption: front and overload is handled by in
Caption: thread injection and again topic for
Caption: previous conversation
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: like all things on office floor
Caption: side tracked
Caption: kind of came across the tech and power
Caption: benchmarks in 2015 and thought hey i can
Caption: do good at this submitted my results and
Caption: went
Caption: that didn't go well
Caption: and let's not talk about that
Caption: but since then and the last round 20
Caption: been doing improvements in the last
Caption: around 20 have become top 20
Caption: and there's a 6.4 million requests per
Caption: second
Caption: about 122 servers entered and the next
Caption: round 21 will have about 126 servers
Caption: entered the number's always growing
Caption: everyone thinks they can run a hp server
Caption: and just like myself and
Caption: just recently i changed the database
Caption: driver and now sitting in top 10.
Caption: and hopefully to keep that position for
Caption: round 21 and i'll be in the top 10
Caption: officially
Caption: so
Caption: how do i do that
Caption: well first off let's get this out there
Caption: programming languages have nothing to do
Caption: with it office 4 is written in standard
Caption: java non-blocking io there's no special
Caption: libraries or anything it just simply
Caption: uses the standard socket libraries and
Caption: does what it needs to do
Caption: and if you want to argue that
Caption: programming languages have nothing to do
Caption: with
Caption: rank number two is just and it's written
Caption: in javascript
Caption: so
Caption: question comes down to what dick takes
Caption: performance
Caption: well i do not write fast software
Caption: hardware deals in speed hardware has
Caption: better clock cycles increased bus speeds
Caption: faster networks
Caption: software deals in efficiency it's
Caption: instructions to the hardware no matter
Caption: how many instructions i can send to the
Caption: hardware i can't make the hardware go
Caption: faster i can only be more efficient in
Caption: my instructions to that hardware
Caption: so
Caption: now i need to understand hardware and
Caption: i'm not an electrical engineer and
Caption: there's all these things and this
Caption: we don't need to understand it heavily
Caption: what you need to really focus on to get
Caption: performance is to get your data to the
Caption: cpu the more data you can get to the cpu
Caption: the more you can process things through
Caption: and the quicker you can get your
Caption: performance through
Caption: so then i said they're going well how do
Caption: i explain this because everything's
Caption: measured in milliseconds microseconds
Caption: nanoseconds and i really can't get a
Caption: feel for that because
Caption: i've never experienced it nanosecond
Caption: because it's just way too fast
Caption: already had too many of them are in the
Caption: talk
Caption: so
Caption: when it comes that i thought well how's
Caption: the best way to describe it and with
Caption: this covert i've been sitting there
Caption: going doing a lot of camping and it's
Caption: like ah
Caption: red's process is camping in cpus is a
Caption: bit like what goes on because if you
Caption: come up with this model you actually sit
Caption: there going well if a process camps on
Caption: the campsite and it needs to get data
Caption: out of its registers or it needs to get
Caption: stuff out of its l1 or l2 caches that's
Caption: a bit like sitting on your campsite and
Caption: going your rescue and getting something
Caption: out nice and quick it's nice and fast
Caption: however if i have to get something from
Caption: ram
Caption: well i kind of got to get in my car and
Caption: drive to the local shops that kind of
Caption: gives you the difference in sort of um
Caption: magnitude difference in terms of
Caption: performance then if i have to go to disk
Caption: what's a bit like driving back to perth
Caption: and back again
Caption: and if i have to do network calls
Caption: it's like driving across australia in
Caption: comparison and hopefully there's no
Caption: covered firewall stopping us getting
Caption: there
Caption: so
Caption: that gives you it now don't quote me on
Caption: the kilometers or the rest but that
Caption: gives you a sense of the magnitude of
Caption: the performance differences of where you
Caption: get the data from so you need to keep
Caption: that in mind when you're writing your
Caption: software
Caption: so the first and most obvious thing
Caption: is don't write small chatty networking
Caption: so don't keep driving back and forth
Caption: across the nullarbor that's inefficient
Caption: it's not going to work
Caption: the other thing is
Caption: don't take lots of separate cars in
Caption: other words don't do lots of small
Caption: requests all your requests have
Caption: overheads with 38 bytes to all the
Caption: packets that go over
Caption: and that adds up if you're sending only
Caption: one or two bytes that starts adding up
Caption: and choking your network you actually
Caption: spend more time with overhead than you
Caption: actually do it so if you looked at it
Caption: it's a bit like this
Caption: you've got all these cars there and
Caption: there's all this wasted space
Caption: now your operating system kind of helps
Caption: you out a little bit with this because
Caption: it's got what's called naggle's
Caption: algorithm or if you ever heard of the no
Caption: tcp delay um flag what that basically
Caption: does is it stops the packet for a moment
Caption: allows it to be filled with more data
Caption: and then sends it on away it's a little
Caption: bit more efficient you think of it it's
Caption: a bit more like a train
Caption: train pulls up to the station waits a
Caption: while gets filled up with data then
Caption: moves out and then it uses more
Caption: efficiency on the network
Caption: now the nice thing is right back at the
Caption: beginning of talk i told you office 4
Caption: processes these things in parallel i
Caption: don't have to wait to the station i've
Caption: got parallel requests coming in i've got
Caption: lots of data feeding back into that
Caption: train station
Caption: so
Caption: office 4 turns the naggles algorithm off
Caption: and writes its own and actually avoids
Caption: sleeping and that gets more efficiency
Caption: through
Caption: now you've got to get talk about threads
Caption: so
Caption: threading is an important part about
Caption: performance and if you think about
Caption: threading it's a bit the same as camping
Caption: on a campsite when the thread comes in
Caption: it turns up from the cpu it's got to
Caption: warm up and sell one or two or two cases
Caption: it's got to get the things going it's a
Caption: bit like turning up the campsite and
Caption: unpacking and getting set up it's kind
Caption: of got to get itself set up and start
Caption: processing so when you look at the
Caption: actual efficiency of using a thread
Caption: you've got the setup time and then the
Caption: processing time
Caption: and when you're talking at this
Caption: performance this becomes important
Caption: because if i start using multiple
Caption: threads i get more setup time now i
Caption: could use that and reduce the latency of
Caption: the request and get the request going
Caption: through faster but there's overall more
Caption: cpu used it's more it's inefficient
Caption: there's more setup time there's more
Caption: things setting up and then actually
Caption: finally getting to process it's more
Caption: overall processing time
Caption: and this becomes worse
Caption: when you try to do parallelism which is
Caption: creating more threads under high
Caption: concurrency because what happens is your
Caption: request comes in it's using a thread for
Caption: the socket process and then all your
Caption: child requests come and steal the rest
Caption: of the cpus
Caption: and then what happens is all the rest of
Caption: the requests are seen they're going well
Caption: can i have a cpu no because they're all
Caption: processing those extra threads you
Caption: created so actually under high
Caption: concurrency doing parallelism and
Caption: actually adding more threads
Caption: ties up your cpus and actually reduces
Caption: your throughput and made worse because
Caption: there's more setups going on so it
Caption: actually becomes double worse
Caption: and then we get into thread coordination
Caption: so
Caption: you've got locks and locks are a bit
Caption: like going to see the camp host and
Caption: going hey can i use the camp kitchen and
Caption: the host is like okay let me check the
Caption: schedule and i'll put you in and work
Caption: all that out
Caption: that takes time that's that's an
Caption: overhead
Caption: whereas you use atomic operation which
Caption: most languages now have it's just a
Caption: quick check is it there is it free
Caption: um and do that as an example in this i
Caption: had two uncontended locks in one of the
Caption: tests that was running at 150 000 per
Caption: second
Caption: just removing those two uncontended
Caption: locks i got up to 450 000 a second
Caption: so at that type of level you can see
Caption: there are overheads these things aren't
Caption: cheap
Caption: and then it gets worse with a thread
Caption: scheduling
Caption: because what happens is when i lock up
Caption: that thread it goes to sleep now being a
Caption: good schedule on an operating system it
Caption: moves another thread in there which then
Caption: starts invalid indication moving its
Caption: stuff into the cache and then what
Caption: happens another thread moves and
Caption: everything starts moving around again
Caption: and then everything needs to be set up
Caption: again and then everything starts
Caption: creating overhead and you go back to
Caption: that problem of having lots of overhead
Caption: to process through your request you're
Caption: spending more time setting up your
Caption: threads then you are actually processing
Caption: and furthermore
Caption: more cpus is not always better
Caption: because the more cpus i have the more
Caption: that has to go across to ram and
Caption: actually access it there's more
Caption: contention
Caption: that all slows you down again
Caption: and if you're actually doing cloud
Caption: consider getting smaller cheaper
Caption: instances of having more of them
Caption: with less you know you've got more ram
Caption: to go around
Caption: i'd be surprised
Caption: but the question is what was the
Caption: threading model that office will use to
Caption: get the six million requests per second
Caption: basically it just had one thread per cpu
Caption: and just processed the thread was hot
Caption: and ready the cases the cases were all
Caption: hot and ready and processing away the
Caption: request comes in and process out it's a
Caption: bit like the campsite already being set
Caption: up by someone you come in enjoy the
Caption: campsite jump out most efficient camping
Caption: you get you don't have all the setup
Caption: tear down and dealing with cleaning and
Caption: all the rest of it you just come in
Caption: enjoy the campsite get out um and that's
Caption: effectively what it does it just runs a
Caption: single thread on the on the cpu and
Caption: processes away
Caption: but there's a gotcha to that problem
Caption: you've got callback threads coming back
Caption: from the database they want to come in
Caption: and say hey i need to process the data
Caption: and then they say give me a cpu and then
Caption: one of the socket threads has to move
Caption: out and then it goes in and then the
Caption: other callback comes in another socket
Caption: thread has to move out and then they all
Caption: start jumbling around they start moving
Caption: and then you get that setup costs again
Caption: and then everything starts slowing down
Caption: now the schedule do their best to
Caption: minimize it but you get that overhead
Caption: what you can do to improve that
Caption: situation
Caption: is do threat affinity
Caption: red affinity binds the thread to run on
Caption: only a single cpu or a group of cpus you
Caption: can set up the configuration you want
Caption: basically you limit what the thread can
Caption: run on so you limit that socket thread
Caption: to only run on the one cpu
Caption: now this is a non-standard java library
Caption: check it out it's quite a good library
Caption: but it is about allowed me access to get
Caption: to do set up that thread affinity
Caption: and what this effectively looks like now
Caption: is you've got the socket thread happily
Caption: camping away using the hot uh l1 and l2
Caption: caches processing away callback thread
Caption: pops in
Caption: uses a bit of space in the side
Caption: does its processing jumps out the socket
Caption: thread jumps back in it's all still nice
Caption: and warm and cozy and continues
Caption: processing through very little overhead
Caption: and it just processes the data through
Caption: as efficiently as possible
Caption: and big thing on this be careful of
Caption: doing this yourself if the web server
Caption: doesn't support it you get into lots of
Caption: fun problems with thread pulls and then
Caption: going to the wrong thread pools and you
Caption: can actually make the situation worse
Caption: you really need to understand what
Caption: you're doing or at least have your web
Caption: servers support this functionality
Caption: so
Caption: who here
Caption: runs database connection pools
Caption: all right who here has about 200
Caption: connections in the database pool
Caption: 100
Caption: 50
Caption: 20
Caption: n
Caption: well the same problems here typically
Caption: and we're talking about the sql variety
Caption: of databases we're not talking about the
Caption: nosql they're a different beast
Caption: altogether the sql databases have
Caption: typically one thread per connection
Caption: because you've got the thread to process
Caption: away and it gets into locks and
Caption: contentions and thread blocks on that
Caption: and processes through
Caption: but we said we want to reduce contention
Caption: because that gets better throughput
Caption: so what you actually want to do is
Caption: minimize the number of threads you
Caption: actually need to minimize the number of
Caption: connections
Caption: kind of counter-intuitive but if you can
Caption: process requests faster you can get more
Caption: of them through
Caption: so if you actually look at postgres or
Caption: hikari which supports this as one of the
Caption: java top-end
Caption: connection pools
Caption: it actually has this as your rule of
Caption: thumb to start
Caption: call count which is not hyper threading
Caption: cause it's actual core counts times two
Caption: plus the effective spindle count
Caption: now with ssds
Caption: we have zero spindles
Caption: so when we've introduced ssds we should
Caption: actually be reducing the number of
Caption: connections not increasing them
Caption: it might be slightly countersuited but
Caption: the same thing comprised you've got
Caption: contention it's slowing everything down
Caption: and you're not getting the throughput
Caption: you want you want to get these things
Caption: through quickly and therefore you get
Caption: more of them
Caption: so if you actually have a four cpu
Caption: database
Caption: you should actually only have eight
Caption: connections that donate
Caption: it might be counterintuitive but next
Caption: time you have database performance
Caption: problems try reducing the number of
Caption: connections and see what happens you
Caption: might actually be pleasantly surprised
Caption: but that's all be interesting but what
Caption: about the code itself
Caption: we're all developers
Caption: vast majority maybe developers are
Caption: interested how do i write this code
Caption: faster or more efficiently
Caption: so first thing don't outsmart the
Caption: compilers
Caption: there are multiple registers on the cpu
Caption: and they all run in parallel
Caption: so
Caption: compilers look for code patterns in your
Caption: code to optimize the register use
Caption: so if you're looking at your code going
Caption: what's that thing doing and i've tried
Caption: to do that to make it highly optimized
Caption: your poor compiler is doing exactly the
Caption: same thing going how do i optimize this
Caption: thing
Caption: basically the rule of this is write
Caption: readable code that camps well
Caption: it sits well doesn't have overheads it
Caption: camps well and it's readable so the
Caption: compiler can see the patterns in it and
Caption: actually optimize it
Caption: the question is what style of readable
Caption: code
Caption: we need to look at memory management to
Caption: have a look at this
Caption: because when you look at memory you've
Caption: got the lower layer
Caption: memory which is all the physical memory
Caption: into there and then what happens is
Caption: applications take buffers out of the
Caption: memory it doesn't take the full process
Caption: full size otherwise you can run too much
Caption: on your cpu it only takes what it needs
Caption: it buffers and then sort of takes more
Caption: and more as it needs from the os and
Caption: then pages there so effectively that's
Caption: what it's doing and then your compiler
Caption: comes in and starts typing that memory
Caption: so it says there's a byte and there's a
Caption: chart which is two bytes and there's an
Caption: int which is four bytes float four bytes
Caption: and references and so forth
Caption: and then we started adding oo on top of
Caption: that so basically
Caption: you've got all these types they're made
Caption: private and then you start accessing
Caption: them by methods
Caption: and this may be slightly controversial
Caption: the functional progress might have an
Caption: issue with me
Caption: but if never legal up is that functions
Caption: then are another level up which just
Caption: don't have the mutate on they don't have
Caption: the settlement they have all the other
Caption: methods but they don't have the
Caption: mutations so you just create muni data
Caption: all the time
Caption: now you can argue which way or form but
Caption: typically you get less bugs as you go
Caption: further up
Caption: but also when you're dealing with this
Caption: level you're dealing with mutation
Caption: you're dealing with changing data you're
Caption: dealing with mutations which means locks
Caption: which means contention which means all
Caption: these bits and pieces on top of it
Caption: but with functional you're just creating
Caption: new things all the time
Caption: no new mutation there's no actual real
Caption: need to lock you're just creating new
Caption: things and processing and if new threads
Caption: need to access it's read-only memory so
Caption: go for it
Caption: caveat on that a lot of functional
Caption: libraries actually use mutation under
Caption: hood just be careful of it but generally
Caption: functional style code which is just
Caption: always creating things without mutation
Caption: doesn't need the locks around it
Caption: gently
Caption: so what we actually do in high
Caption: performance is we prefer functional code
Caption: but
Caption: we can use memory to our advantage
Caption: so if i was to parse a http get request
Caption: in a object or functional type of way
Caption: this would be the kind of thing you do
Caption: you go you know buffer tostring and then
Caption: check that the string starts with get
Caption: a lot of operations in there
Caption: but i can kind of know that
Caption: http is us actually octates so if i use
Caption: the compiler typing
Caption: i can just check the first three bytes
Caption: to go ah is the first byte of g is the
Caption: second byte an e and there's the third
Caption: byte t now i've done three operations a
Caption: lot less
Caption: but that's not good enough
Caption: i can actually use the knowledge the
Caption: registers are 64 bits
Caption: that's 8 bytes
Caption: so i can read the long out of the buffer
Caption: and go right let's mask out the
Caption: remaining five bytes and then just check
Caption: the first three bytes now i've done it
Caption: in two operations
Caption: and if i need to check the put one more
Caption: operation
Caption: a lot less involved
Caption: and when you start looking at http
Caption: limited parsing and bits and pieces you
Caption: can actually use this to advantage you
Caption: can sit there and go right read out
Caption: eight bytes you mask out the bytes zero
Caption: out the bytes for the character you're
Caption: looking for trigger and overflow if
Caption: there's an overflow bit because all hps
Caption: is the last seven bite or seven bits of
Caption: the bite and the top end bite is one
Caption: bite it triggers an overflow into the
Caption: top end bite
Caption: mask that out and then check if there's
Caption: an overflow if there's an overflow in
Caption: every bite
Caption: your character's not in there
Caption: so instead of having to do a for loop
Caption: which is eight operations and eight
Caption: checks which is about 16 operations in
Caption: total
Caption: you can do this in four
Caption: quarter of the effort
Caption: and this is what's called bit twiddling
Caption: if you've never heard the
Caption: term and there's bit twiddlers out there
Caption: quite literally um
Caption: and you can see sites a lot of the
Caption: universities have sites that actually
Caption: show you all bitterly tricks and so
Caption: forth and this is very useful in
Caption: shortcut you know shortcutting
Caption: repetitive hd process
Caption: now in office for it's used only for
Caption: that the rest of the application server
Caption: is using functional compiler upgrades
Caption: code
Caption: and the thing on this is typically there
Caption: is little value bit twitter in your
Caption: application logic because the compiler
Caption: will come in and optimize it for you
Caption: um
Caption: so the moral of this is write
Caption: functionally styled application code
Caption: that the compiler generally optimizes
Caption: for you
Caption: so
Caption: in summary
Caption: hardware is about fast
Caption: software is about efficiency
Caption: understand the hardware at least in a
Caption: logical level kind of understand that
Caption: map of australia and where the cost is
Caption: of getting the data
Caption: code design is more important than
Caption: coding language when i start hearing
Caption: people complaining this language is
Caption: fascinating
Caption: it's how you write the code and manage
Caption: it is more important
Caption: minimize the number of threads ideally
Caption: one per cpu minimize the number of
Caption: database connections you may be very
Caption: surprised when you do that consider
Caption: topping
Caption: operations over locking having on that
Caption: if you've got critical sections don't do
Caption: that
Caption: but try and use algorithms that use
Caption: atomic operations rather than critical
Caption: sections
Caption: more often scaling instances is better
Caption: than more cpus because you're not
Caption: contending over ram and consider
Caption: functional programming pro practices
Caption: because lack of mutation
Caption: all across cpus
Caption: oh on that amount
Caption: thank you and i'm happy to take
Caption: questions with time